[Music]
imagine for a moment
what the world will look like in 10
years time not much different
what about 50 or 100 years from now in
this future world what will our cities
look like
how we travel to work school or college
and what kind of new technologies we
have at our disposal
what will the planet look like and will
we be any happier than before
now this particular question is by no
means new predictions and prophecies of
the future are as old as time itself
what have been some past predictions of
the time we're in right now the early
21st century
an age filtered through the internet
algorithms and data
let's see if they're onto something so
let's start by going back 120 years ago
in the 1900s the invention of the first
airplane opened massive potential in
transportation
and sparked the imaginations of the
public in germany a chocolate company
called
hildebrands made a series of
commemorative postcards imagining their
life in the year 2000.
they speculated that the world would go
airborne people will take to the skies
in their very own personal airships and
gliders
the same series also speculated that
housing blocks will travel via giant
steam trains
although entire cities will be encased
in glass to protect them from the rain
they even imagined some vacations spent
up at the north pole
sadly maybe that one might come true one
day
take a look at these french prints they
also depict life in the year 2000
but this time were made around 1910 once
again
it was the future for the aviators who
will seemingly replace the motor car by
the year 2000
this one pictures a man in a glider
grabbing a glass of wine for the road
or should i say skies it's a bit like a
modern day drive through
this man is getting a haircut from his
mechanical barber
now i would use the term robot but it
won't be coined until 1920
10 years from now in the classroom this
contraption is fed books
whose words are then played directly
into the student's ears
an early audiobook perhaps whilst it
seems that fashionable go unchanged
these quaint imaginings from the start
of the 20th century show a great sense
of optimism for the future
it reminds me of the steampunk genre a
future vision and aesthetic
but stuck in victorian technologies like
steam power and industrial machinery
as well as goggles and top hats
now moving towards the 1920s and we get
another vision of the future
fritz slang's 1927 masterpiece
metropolis has some great resources for
the topic
in this film cities now supersized
featuring mega skyscrapers expansive
highways and beautiful robots
all with a jazz age art deco aesthetic
it was no doubt influenced by
contemporary new york
which during the 20s was undergoing
rapid vertical growth
just look at how the city changed from
the 1910s to the 1930s
it's also in the 1920s where we see the
first flying cars
this 1923 drawing by early science
fiction writer hugo guernsbach
introduces the first wheeled helicar a
levitating vehicle speculated to enter
the market in 1973.
so now let's take a realistic look at
the road ahead
and what tomorrow's motorists can expect
in the years to come
[Music]
speed safety and comfort will be the
keynotes of tomorrow's highways
a multi-colored highway system may
enable the motorist to reach his
destination by following the correct
color strip
the increased speed of tomorrow's
automobile will demand that highway
signs be larger and more simple to read
so that the motorist can anticipate his
moves well in advance
if visibility is poor our windshield
becomes a radar screen
showing the outline of objects ahead or
fog may be eliminated by dispelling
devices along the right-of-way
other predictions of the future include
one 1950s article
that too imagines what the year 2000
will be like it predicts that the future
will be one of convenience and luxury
this picture phone will allow us to buy
products from a screen
and have it delivered without leaving
the home then again
it also predicts that all our food will
be made from a sort of flavored sawdust
that can be recycled into clothes
confusing i know most interesting is the
role atomic energy plays in the 1950s
future
after the detonations of the atomic bomb
in japan the world was awakened to the
immense potentials of nuclear power
in the same article it speculates that
atomic power will provide 100
of the world's power and by the year
2000 that street lamps will be replaced
by micro
suns suspended 200 feet in the air and
powered by uranium
in reality nuclear power only really
accounts for 10 of global energy
and there are no micro suns in sight
when we come to the 60s and 70s the age
of the moon landings and later star wars
visions of the future changed
accordingly in my mind
this is perfectly laid out in the
hanna-barbera 1962 animated series the
jetsons
which follows the everyday lives of an
ordinary nuclear family in the far
far future of 2062. despite the
wonderful technologies
it all seems somehow very 60s the
hometown of orbit city
is designed in the googie architectural
style an early futuristic style that was
extremely popular at the time
even their outfits have some sort of
retro futuristic look
by the end of the 60s once the space
race reached a climactic head in the
apollo moon landings
many predicted that mankind will soon
reach mars in the next 50 years
and as the 70s came and went the dream
of space colonization continued
this nasa video imagines that by the
year 2000 humans would have begun to
colonise space
opening a permanent settlement on mars
take a look
this is taurus the concept that has
evolved from the work of these teams of
scientists and engineers
they believe the huge space colony could
be built before the year 2000
from dairy farms to manufacturing the
concept of living and working in space
is a possibility with existing
technology
that new space home located a quarter of
a million miles from earth
would even have a far out address
in the 80s and 90s as personal computing
and home technology were just getting
underway
our imaginations for the future changed
once again
in back to future 2 the 1989 movie about
time travel
doc and marty visit earth in 2015. in it
were featured hoverboards
thumb payment systems and an automatic
dog walker
yet oblique imagining comes from 1984's
the terminator
predicts a future in which rogue
technological giant skynet
takes over the world is just one of a
slew of predictions about the dangers of
oncoming technology
and finally as the 1990s came along
video games offered more digital
immersion than ever realized
and the advent of the world wide web and
its growing popularity offered the
possibility of living inside a virtual
reality
and hence the rapid growth of vr
headsets in this time
including the ill-fated virtual boy from
nintendo
only now with the oculus rift and
playstation vr headsets
are beginning to finally live up to
those 1990s streams
looking back at visions of the future
every decade and we get a very diverse
picture
the year 2000 looks very different in
the 1910s to the 1950s
and the 1970s and yes some predictions
have come true
like the development of the driverless
car or shopping at simple press of a
button
but a lot of far off let's go back to
that question at the start of the video
what will our future really look like in
his book
homodeus author yuval noah harari
expects that humanity will begin its
quest to immortality
with humans being able to sustain life
of over 150 years
equally projects may be underway to
develop cybernetic enhancements on
humans
giving them improved strength and
intelligence these indeed could be
reality by the end of the century
it is believed that by 2050 nearly half
the amazon rainforest would have been
deforested
wildfires might have tripled in regions
like california and some in australia
and by 2056 global temperatures may have
risen by 3 degrees celsius
and if that's too depressing for you
don't worry by the year 2100
space travel could decrease in price
enough for humans to visit and perhaps
even colonize the planet mars
the thing about the future though is
that no one really knows what's going to
happen
all we have to go on is current trends
and then make guesses
but as we've seen each present moment
imagines a future with themselves
clearly in it
taking advantage of the newest
technology of the day to its furthest
limits
the 1910 saw a future with a newly
invented airplane taking center stage
the 1950s saw a future of atomic power
and driverless cars
and the 1960s and 70s saw their future
in the stars
perhaps influenced by the ongoing space
programs
my best guess is to expect the
unexpected after all
who could imagine the way 2020 has
turned out people in 2120 will likely
look back at our future predictions just
like the way we look at those made in
1910
old antiquated maybe even a less naive
that's my prediction at least
hey thanks for watching if you like my
content and want to see more
subscribe to hilargo maybe add a like or
a comment i'll be sure to read them
do check out matt novak's blog
paleofuture where he provides countless
articles and resources
uncovering what past decades thought
about their time in the future
his articles were incredibly useful in
researching this video
anyway i look forward to seeing you next
time goodbye
you